The empire may have fallen,
but my ambitions never wavered.
I am grand Admiral Thrawn,
and my return is inevitable.
I could use the help
In this war,
you'll face more than just droids
as your master
is my responsibility to prepare you.
I won't always be there
to look out for you.
Welcome back everyone
This is the way
we've got a little Ahsoka Episode
8 finale footage to break down.
I know there's a bunch of theories
and hanging plot threads
that they have to pay off
a lot of questions about that.
we know the throne is supposed to catch
the New Republic with their pants
around their ankles,
so we'll break it all down.
for better, for worse.
A lot of this is all meant
to set up the Thrawn movie,
so do expect a lot of hanging plot threads
and cliffhangers in the finale.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
There's going to be a bunch of crossovers
with the upcoming series.
We're also doing a giveaway
for The Mandalorian on Blu ray.
All you have to do to Enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your finaly theories
in the comments.
Onyema winner in this video.
But careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far on the show.
just starting
with the elephant in the room.
The throne in the room. The footage
we can now see from the trailer.
This has all been in the previous
trailers.
Is Thrawn onboard the hyperspace ring?
in it seems like what they've done
with the Ahsoka trailers
that they did a house of the Dragon
Game of Thrones
kind of thing where in all the house
of the Dragon trailers they put footage
from like the very last shot of the series
in the early trailers.
so this scene is Thrawn.
The hyperspace ring might not be the exact
final shot of the finale,
but they'll probably end the finale
on a cliffhanger
similar to a moment like this
where the hyperspace
ring enters the main galaxy
with this chimera star destroyer.
He looks out over the planet like a boss.
It's the making of the Lord of the Rings
joke.
It's the return of the King.
Then they slam to the credits and
just pick up the next part of the story.
During the Mandalorian Season four
or the Skeleton Crew series,
or even saving a lot of it
for the Thrawn movie.
the next actual Star Wars show is Skeleton
Crew with Jude Law and those kids.
we got a little trailer footage
for that back at Star Wars celebration.
I did a video for us all.
Link it down in the description below,
supposedly he's meant to be a former Jedi
and for some reason
they get stranded on their ship
in what might be this other pretty galaxy
We know that it's meant to cross over
with the Sokka
The Mandalorian Season four.
Everything is happening.
This part of the timeline
in those characters
will appear in the Thrawn movie
in some way.
so tying this all together. A lot.
Have you been theorizing
that they'll end the Ahsoka
finale with Thrawn
returning to the main galaxy in a Soga?
Sabine Everyone else getting stranded in
the other galaxy on the prettier planet.
just isn't.
It seems like they take a huge l
The New Republic in general
taking a lot of L's right now
acting so stupid
they kind of deserve what they're getting.
It seems like I think they really want you
to hate the New Republic.
there only a couple of ways for Ahsoka
and the others
to make it back to the main galaxy.
Now that the prequels are gone in most,
the Thrones minefield is still active
around the planet.
So even if they were able to have a way
to call the prequels back,
they probably wouldn't
come close to the planet
So early theories right now, were they?
Either
Ahsoka finds a way to attach her ship
to the whole the hyperspace ring
without Thrawn sensors detecting it
and just hitching a ride
back to the main galaxy, or much simpler.
They just get stranded in the other galaxy
and have to find another way home. no.
If Jude Law and the people from Skeleton
Crew are going to that other galaxy,
they might be their ticket home
before the Thrawn movie starts.
a lot of people also want to see Grogu The
Mandalorians also help Ahsoka get back.
but it's no good.
Getting stranded in the other galaxy
would be a way to explain
why she isn't around.
During the events
of the Mandalorian season four
to show everyone
the evidence of Thrones plans
so that the New Republic can prepare.
Like that's the whole idea is that Dave
Filoni really wants Thrawn
to catch the New Republic
with their pants around their ankles
so they get their asses
handed to them, at least at first.
part of the problem
though with this whole Thrawn storyline is
that we kind of know what happens later
in the timeline,
like The New Republic
still exists later in the timeline.
So we know that ultimately
he doesn't succeed,
that's one of the only weaknesses
of doing stuff earlier in the timeline
is that like,
you know, some of the bigger plot points,
but there's still like a lot of big
questions about how that all plays out,
like, we don't really know what happens
with the so-called later in the timeline.
We don't know what really happens with
Grogu when he gets a little bit older.
But think about the timeline this way.
Thrawn would need a little time
after he makes it back to the main galaxy
to marshal
the forces of the Shadow Council.
Because you have all these different
factions of Imperials all over the galaxy
and it's going to take them a while
to bring their giant fleet together.
in if a giant imperial
fleet just posted up somewhere near
the outer rim,
the New Republic would know about it.
As dumb as they seem right now.
So they just have to have a way to explain
why they don't learn about Thrawn
returning for a little while longer.
just be way easier for that to happen
if Ahsoka gets stuck in the other galaxy
and it's like the mandalorians
that learn about Thrawn first
before the New Republic sees the evidence,
they can just make the Mandalorian
sort of like the first line of defense
because the whole thing
at the end of season
three was showing
that they were reactivating
the great force,
retaking the mantle of a planet,
making preparations
for the larger Star Wars to come.
So if anybody learns about Thrawn first,
it should be the Mandalorians Grogu you,
Mando, all those characters
They can just have Mando and Grogu
you learn about them
on one of their random bounty missions
early in the season is like,
Wait a minute,
there's a giant fleet out here
at this time Here, Star
Destroyer looks a little bit different
from the other star destroyers.
why is there a star destroyer to begin
with? grow.
You can also start sussing out
what's going on
with the nice sisters, too, in the force.
Like, wait a minute, I get some weird
vibes from these nice sisters.
this thing about the Nightsisters.
Two is their whole nine sister zombie army
that they plan to resurrect.
That's the special cargo
that Thrawn has been loading.
It's going to take them some time to all
raise those from the dead.
They can't just do it
on the drop of a hat.
normally, in order to raise them from
the dead, they need that special green
magic energy which can only be found on
Dathomir in the main galaxy.
there maybe couple retcons with that.
But I think that's why the Dathomir planet
is meant to be so important
in the main galaxy.
Why the Nightsisters
originally settled there
when they got stuck in the main galaxy.
the other really big question
is what's going on with Baylan Skoll
in this mystery power
that he feels calling to him on Meridia
because Rey Stephenson died in real life
before the season came out.
Maggie rest in peace really sucks
because he's amazing during this season
is the day when he probably intended
on having a cliffhanger with him
where he finds out what he's looking for.
But they don't really explain it
until the Sokka Season two
or like the Thrawn movie.
no. I don't know if they plan to recast
his character before that Thrawn movie or
Mando Season four, wherever the character
would have originally appeared next.
Or they just write him out of season
two in the Thrawn movie.
But right now
it seems like they'll be forced
to have some kind of cliffhanger
for his storyline.
then they use the next couple of years
before the Thrawn movie
comes out to just figure out
what happens with his character.
like in the finale.
He'll find what he's looking for
and then just seemingly disappear
and they don't fully explain
what happens till way, way later.
it's kind of like what happened
to the Korra doing character.
These kind of had to explain
what happened to her offscreen.
They made it seem like she died offscreen.
I know
there've been a lot of apple off theories
about this power that he's seeking,
but I don't think they're doing Apple off
from Legends.
She was a Legends
version of the mother in the mortise Gods
family like the father,
the son, the daughter.
The mother was a character
they introduced in the Legends
books after the Clone Wars
Mortis episodes.
So she's not meant to be Canon.
The book that introduced
the character came out right before Disney
bought Star Wars. That's
why she's a Legends character.
the whole idea is that she was meant to be
a human woman to serve the mortis gods.
And they just came to think of her
as the mother Until one day she sought
to gain immortality like the mortis gods
had so she could live with them forever.
She drank from this
wellspring of the force on mortis,
and it turned her into this giant
cosmic entity.
now, it just seems it's more likely that
Baylan power he's seeking is something
totally different.
Like that might have something to do
with the Zeffo mentioned on the Nightsisters
Temple.
Well,
I've done a couple of videos about him.
His name was Kujet.
He was a big part of the Jedi
Fallen Order Jedi Survivor games
because they included that Easter egg.
It means that the events of those games
are canon to the main Star Wars story.
So it's more likely that Dave Fleming is
pulling in like some classic canon stuff.
but it could also be something
totally different.
Like I said,
I think they're going to spend
the next couple of years
figuring out exactly what that is.
There'll be just some giant cliffhanger
with this storyline.
Shin Hati
seems like she's going to return to
the main galaxy with Thrawn,
which Baylan told her to do.
there's supposed to be at least
one more Anakin Skywalker cameo scene.
I think it'll be Force Ghost and again,
giving a soldier a pep talk.
But they might use his cameo
to set up the Thrawn movie a little bit,
where he explains to her that even though
they take a huge l all hope is not lost,
I could just see Ahsoka
now, like, okay, there's
this little creature called Grogu
who could you please take?
Your force goes back to the main galaxy
and just warn him
what happened and tell him to find a way
to bring us back.
The other thing
too, is the world between worlds
they featured as so prominently midway
through the season.
They could also use
that as one of the keys.
The way to resolve some of this storyline.
But post all your predictions
for the finale in the comments in Ahsoka
season two because they did start working
on season two before the strike started.
So it seems pretty likely
that they will continue doing that
now that they've resolved that.
The other big thing is
how do you think the Skeleton Crew series
is going to cross over with
what's happening right now?
Because we know that it's
going to cross over in some way
just be way easier
if they come to the other galaxy in a show
because the other characters
are still there.
I believe that that show
was supposed to premiere early 2024.
Originally it was going to be in December,
but then they delayed everything
this year by a few months.
So we'll probably get the trailer for that
after the Loki series comes out.
big Reminder to Loki.
Season two Episode one starts next week.
My episode video for that
will post every Friday just like normal.
The Mandalorian Season four
might not make it out by the end of 2024.
They haven't started shooting that yet,
but they did finish writing it
before the strike started
so they can start shooting that
as soon as the actors
part of the strike gets resolved,
which might be the next couple of weeks.
when we start learning
more about what's going on
during Mando season
four, also doing some more bonus videos
for that.
congratulations.
Rossi Zervos You're the giveaway winner
for my last big Ahsoka video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
And it would be cool if Roku helps, so can
the others get back to the main galaxy.
my full episode 8 finale video
we'll post next week.
After they release it,
click here for my Ahsoka Episode 7
video and click here
for all my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe. And this is the way!